the history of philosophy has been
dominated by competing arguments around
the ideas of free will and determinism
simply stated the issue hangs on whether
human beings should be thought of as
fundamentally free to choose their
actions and mold their lives or whether
they should be deemed as being at heart
determined by forces beyond their
control be they called fate biology
politics or class
the debate has been long-running and
hugely vicious it began in ancient
Greece was picked up by the Romans
dominated Christian philosophy and
rumbles on to this day among
philosophers psychologists and
neuroscientists part of the reason why
the question seems so hard to find a
conclusive answer to is that it's almost
always framed in objective terms as if
we might discover whether either free
will or determinism could be an
advisable interpretation for human
beings in general but in truth the
debate becomes more interesting and more
relevant if we change the parameters of
the question and ask simply is an idea
of free will or of determinism more or
less relevant to me all of us will have
different needs in this area depending
on our contrasting levels of two
psychological qualities defeatism on the
one hand aspiration on the other there
are people whose levels of defeatism
have grown so high they too readily
declare that responsibility for things
always lies outside of themselves the
course of their life is they tell us
entirely determined by parents school
the government the bosses the media
anyone but themselves the result can be
radical underachievement
and self-deceit but there is another
kind of difficulty created in people
whose levels of aspiration have grown so
high on the basis of overly exaggerated
notions of freewill
they will deem that everything about
their lives is capable of change they'll
declare that they can achieve all things
simply through an exercise of the will
their career and income their
relationships and prospects are all
apparently subject to dramatic change
it's an inspiring philosophy but one
that also can lead and things don't work
out as they never do in all areas to
bitterness and rage each of us needs to
decide for ourselves whether we should
have greater faith in determinism or in
freewill we should ask how much of the
suffering in our lives could be traced
back to a defeatist attitude and how
much might be traced back to reckless
aspiration some of us need to dial up a
faith in free will others need more of a
mellow
absence of determinism the oldest debate
in philosophy isn't beyond answering we
just have to answer it more personally
with more of a sense of what we need to
believe in to be calmer and more
fulfilled perhaps the wisest way to
navigate the debate between free will
and determinism was worked out by the
ancient Roman philosophers of the stoic
school these Stoics propose that we
should see ourselves as always hovering
between a free and a determined state
and they invented a powerful image to
evoke our condition as creatures able at
times to affect great change and yet
never far from being subject to
immensely powerful external necessities
we are they said like dogs who've been
tied to an unpredictable cart our leash
is long enough to give us a degree of
leeway but it's not long enough ever
just to allow us to wander wherever we
please
a dog will naturally hope to go wherever
it wants to set the Stoics
but if it cannot then it's better for
the animal to be trotting obediently
behind the cart rather than dragged and
strangled by it to reflect that we too
are never without a leash around our
neck may help to reduce the violence of
our protest against events which fear
away from our intentions this may sound
like a recipe for activity but as the
Stoics insisted it's no less
unreasonable to accept something as
necessary when it isn't as to rebel
against something when it is it's our
reason that must judge the difference
and this is where we have a big
advantage over the dog a dog will
probably not at first grasp that he is
even tied to a cart nor understand the
connection between the swerves of the
cart and the pain around his neck so he
won't be able to predict where the cart
is going and adjust his position
accordingly but reason enables us to
theorize with considerable accuracy
about the path of the cart or destiny
which offers us a chance unique among
living beings to increase our sense of
freedom by ensuring a good slack between
our desires and what we cannot change
reason allows us to calculate when our
wishes are an irrevocable conflict with
reality and then bits us to submit
ourselves willingly rather than angrily
or bitterly to necessity we may be
powerless to alter certain events but we
always remain free to choose our
attitude towards them and it's in an
unprotected acceptance of what is truly
necessary that we may be able to find a
distinctive serenity and freedom at the
school of life we believe in developing
emotional intelligence to that end we've
also created a whole range of products
to support that growth find out more at
the link on the screen now